Ryan Reynolds on Deadpool 3 at Disney
it's just a win for everyone involved
III see this is an absolute win how's it
going everybody it's Warren welcome back
to my channel to cosmic wonder where we
talk about all things related to Marvel
and of course the MCU today we have news
about Deadpool 3 now some of you may
have heard the news already with Ryan
Reynolds his recent interview with Total
Film magazine but apparently this news
may not be all what it seems to be on
the surface now it's been a while since
we've got to any type of Deadpool 3 news
and fans have been wondering what is
going on since Ryan Reynolds teased us
not too long ago stating that Marvel
Studios was working on Deadpool 3 but a
new report suggests something else so
let's talk about this new interview with
Ryan Reynolds on Deadpool 3 and what it
means for the future film in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so we'll talk about
this new interview talk about what he
said in previous interviews when to
expect
Deadpool 3 and of course the big
question will Deadpool be rated R even
though the next Deadpool film is going
to be in the MCU if you're new be sure
to subscribe when notifications turned
on to stay up to date on everything
relating to Deadpool 3 and the MCU and
I'm also starting weekly giveaways next
Monday the 4th of May so ever since
Disney bought Fox Deadpool fans have
been wondering how exactly Disney the
family-friendly company is going to be
able to handle the Merc with the mouth
will Disney let Deadpool continue to be
rated R that's the biggest question that
everybody has right now and it seems
like even Ryan Reynolds doesn't really
seem to know what Disney is going to do
in a recent interview with Total Film
magazine he opened up about the subject
in the interview he said oh man I really
don't know it's just all so new with it
being over at Marvel now and you know
figuring out the ins and outs as much as
I can from where I sit we'll see
he was then asked about his adjustment
going from being an outsider to being
over at Fox to being an insider now
being at Marvel Studios in which he
replied I don't feel like an insider at
all I think once I'm more intimate with
it
we get to make a Deadpool three if or
when we get to make a Deadpool three
I'll probably have a better perspective
on that but I'm a huge fan of Marvel and
how they make movies so when Disney
bought Fox
I only saw that as a good thing Deadpool
hopefully being allowed to play in that
sandbox I think is just a win for
everyone involved but we'll certainly
see now this reply definitely took a lot
of people by surprise especially if you
consider that barely five months ago
Ryan Reynolds was on a live talk show
talking about how Marvel Studios is
already developing Deadpool 3 so Ryan
asks Ryan is there another Deadpool
movie coming to the franchise and Ryan
Reynolds says yeah we're working on it
right now he says we're working on it
with our whole team and we're over at
Marvel now the big leagues and then
again he says we're working on it so
there is clearly something more that
meets the eye going on right here what I
think is that things are actually more
official than ever and here's the reason
why we had this interview five months
ago this was in December of ryan
reynolds confirming work on deadpool 3
he confirmed that him and his team were
over at Marvel now and they were working
on it and on Instagram he even posted a
couple of pictures teasing Deadpool over
at the MCU he posted one photo teasing
that Deadpool could show up in Phase
five and then he posted a photo of him
physically at Marvel Studios as
headquarters so based off of what he has
said and based off of the fact that he
posted a picture of him at Marvel
Studios he's definitely met with them
and a lot of conversations have been
going on what I think has actually
happened is that Ryan Reynolds and his
Deadpool team have been meeting with
Marvel Studios since they're at Marvel
Studios now and they've decided on the
direction and when they're going to do
Deadpool 3 I think that plans could be
official now but Marvel Studios told
Ryan Reynolds you can't say anything
because it sounds like Ryan Reynolds is
being particularly careful in what he
says because he knows that it's going to
be public since this is an interview and
he doesn't want to give anything away
and he doesn't want to make anybody mad
at Marvel Studios the big leagues as he
called it but there have already been a
lot of rumors
around that Deadpool could actually show
up in Phase five and not to mention
again that Instagram photo that he
posted teased phase five and actually
said phase five on it so although
nothing is confirmed as of the moment it
sure does seem like we could get
Deadpool in phase five but now again the
question is will it be rated R Disney
doesn't really do rated R movies however
everything that we've heard so far about
Deadpool being over at Disney has said
that they're open to it and a lot of
people would probably say that Deadpool
won't really be the same if it's not
rated R one thing that Marvel has done
pretty well is develop really great
characters and Deadpool is probably the
one character that Fox actually got
right he has the same attitude and tone
that he has in the comics and if they
changed that and tone him down then he
won't really be the same character and
Marvel Studios and Disney is smart they
know what makes good characters they
know it makes good movies and they know
if they tone him down the movies won't
be as good and probably a lot of people
won't go see the movies and not to
mention that Deadpool is one of the
highest-grossing rated-r movies of all
time so they know that changing him to a
pg-13 Deadpool probably isn't for the
best and as Ryan Reynolds mentioned he
has this team over at Marvel Studios now
the same team from the previous Deadpool
films so if the same team for Deadpool 1
and Deadpool 2 are working on the film
it's most likely going to have the same
tone and it's most likely going to be
rated R so I don't think there's too
much to worry about Deadpool being rated
R I think it's going to remain rated R
obviously they'll tone him down if he
crosses over with characters like
spider-man or any of the other Avengers
but for the most part in the MCU I think
we're going to be getting the same old
Wade Wilson that we know and I think
things are well underway right now with
Deadpool 3 at Marvel Studios I think
Ryan Reynolds is just being super
cautious now that he's with Marvel
Studios but let me know what you think
about what he said in this recent
interview do you think he's being
cautious or do you think we may not get
a Deadpool film for some time let me
know what you think in the comments down
below don't forget to give a like for
Deadpool and subscribe when
notifications turned on so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to
Deadpool and the MCU
you can follow me on Twitter for live
updates and as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
you